let's go instead to the 267 area code
caller from 267 go ahead hi there
my name is William Jones I wanted to
talk to you about the couple of videos
that you've made in the past regarding
you know black gun owners that uh have
been shot by police okay yeah do you
think that a problem with the media is
selective coverage I mean by that is
people will find some news stories that
seem to fit a political slant that they
have yes absolutely so you have to you
know when you talk about this is a big
issue like what's an example that I
talked about
so for example with pit bull bites right
you will often see people believe that
pit bulls are statistically more likely
to bite because a high percentage of the
bite media stories are about pit bulls
but then what you have to ask is is a
pit bull bite story more likely to be
covered than a chihuahua bite story and
then you very quickly start to
understand sort of the self-fulfilling
prophecy that that exists there the
vicious circle so conceptually yes what
you're describing exists now we have to
analyze whether it exists with police
shootings of legally licensed and armed
black men right and that's exactly what
I'm getting at so there's a negative
effect when you make videos like that
even if that's not your intent to make
it seem like it's a prevailing problem
because you're not going into the
statistics you're just going to serve
with a news article that's about this
and it paints the perspective that this
is a widespread problem and you also
mentioned about how the NRA doesn't talk
about doesn't come to the defense of
these people but I just saw a article
about you know there was a issue back in
the past with a female cop that shot a
male ended up in his apartment building
and
I saw the article about how the NRA was
that if he had a gun he would have
survived the situation so yeah but that
okay so hold on what let's take these
issues that you're bringing up good
points but let's analyze these one by
one it's very different to say so if if
there's a critique that hey hold on
here's five stories prominent stories of
legally armed black men where the NRA
did not come to their defense it's not a
counter to that to say here's a story of
a black guy who wasn't armed and the NRA
says that he should have been because
that doesn't tell us that
had he been armed the NRA would be
defending him right it's very easy to be
the NRA and when the guy was not armed
say hey Fiat a gun II could have
defended himself that's very different
than actually coming to the defense
publicly for these legally licensed
black gun owners so I don't think that
that's a good I don't think that that's
a counterexample at all if I even
attempt to be a counter it's a it's just
meant to show you that there's other
examples that are out there that aren't
exactly the way you paint them when you
cover these two stories I disagree that
an example of that and the that's what
I'm telling you William and maybe we're
not maybe I'm not being clear it's not
an it's an example of something totally
unrelated what I've been pointing out is
that when you have prominent stories of
white individuals that have been in
similar circumstances as the ones that
we've been reported the NRA will very
publicly do everything from raise money
to them to make commercials around these
individuals and that we have prominent
examples of legally carrying black men
where they're not doing that you've
cited an example of something that's a
totally different thing which is they
once said a black guy should have had a
gun to defend himself it's just an
example of something very different that
doesn't in any way negate what I'm
saying well there's other things that
are that are didn't need to be addressed
as well okay because there's the the
majority of America is white so he was
you would expect the majority of any
example in America to be representative
of white people and also you there's
tons of
apples of you know car carrying in our
AP people people that have had licenses
that have been shot by police that the
media hasn't got been covered it hasn't
covered them okay again we'll really
counter what it wouldn't so the fact
that lots of stories just aren't covered
by the media that's fair that's where
you've started and I thought you were on
pretty solid footing there but now
you're saying something else you're
saying that lots of stories that never
make it into the media the NRA just
doesn't say anything one way or other
that that's fine but what we're talking
about is the NRA s predilection for
saying nothing in the defense of these
legally licensed black men who are
carrying weapons and are shot or
something happens compared to when the
person is white the fact that lots of
stories just aren't covered is neither
here nor there
clothing boys if there's not a public
story I'll see how will be a public like
the NRA will come to the public
offensive is not in the public sphere
that's exactly right so what we're
talking about is within the sphere of
these shootings that are publicized and
we can debate whether they are
publicized in proportion to the degree
to which they happen based on race
that's the observation we're making how
does the NRA react to the stories that
are publicized you you've kind of gone
you've gone to on three different
arguments which are all legitimate
conversations but separate conversations
well I mean they don't come to the sense
of every single scenario that's come
about the media do you do that the NRA
does not always come out on every gun
related story in the media that's true
right there you go so there's gonna be
people these stories where they don't
come the defense of whether it's white
or black now we can't we can't just come
to the conclusion without further
evidence that it's because they're black
that that they are comes with a sense of
these small examples because they
they're not you're right you're right we
need more information to definitively
say that it's because they're black the
trend is worrying though is my point
William I gotta go I think I understand
what you're saying I don't know that
that you're giving me reason
reexamine what we're suspecting is going
on but I agree with you that we need
more evidence to say definitively that
it's because the individuals are black
appreciate the call let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we are taking more calls quick
break and we will be back with more of
your calls right after this